crab feast you know it's all about this
is the crab fish I'm yelling [ __ ] that
you ain't got a half me cuz you could
trust that every to see you already you
know or I am thankless Arkansas you go
above ground cool goes better than most
Jane Austen self-diagnosed
go down low this week last week here we
go again for crappie
[Music]
Oh
ah back to the crab feast y'all the
Tuesday I'll cry me for that ass got my
eyes open the whole time when I'm Chris
Tucker I wanna see it I didn't see [ __ ]
down so oh man good to touch your pitch
good to touch your sickle-cell great to
be here with you great to be here with
Feaster Nash Jay Larson here Jay Larson
comma calm Jay Larson comedy on all
social media hope everybody had a great
4th of July yeah so you guys like in
last week's episode was great to see you
guys being active even during the
holiday I was not
if you missed the episode because of the
holiday you got to go back and listen uh
Ida's podcast go back and P they'e her
her life stories unbelievable oh my it
really is a great up so we got another
great episode this week and dude our
fourth of July was amazing by the way we
rented a house we were up in Northern
California I didn't post one so social
media wasn't on it didn't even watch TV
for nine days we had a flagpole and a
flag every day we braised the flag and
take it down it was the greatest you
gonna raise the flag Danny increase the
flag anyway I hope you guys had a great
time with your family and your loved
ones I've got some stuff coming up next
Friday the 21st I'll be in Boston at
Patriots place out in Foxborough doing a
show for a show time with Rob Gronkowski
if anyone's out there and interested to
come to that I should have a link they
should be sending me a link so I'll post
as soon as I have it and then Portland
Oregon I will be there at a helium the
3rd 4th and 5th of August why don't we
all plan on coming out on the 3rd or the
4th you know I mean the fifth Saturday
whatever but go get your tickets I tried
to get a code I couldn't get one so just
say you're with the crab beasts and
they're going to give better seating
that's all I can really offer I wish I
could offer more if I double it I'm not
going to Dublin anymore I can't go do
that trip any of you were going out
there so I just let you know when in
October 6th and 7th La Jolla Comedy
Store I'll be out there it's way down
the road Ryan Sickler sickle-cell always
great to be here with you great to tell
everyone
what got black Jay Larson on Pinterest
Ryan Sickler on all social media Ryan
Sickler calm in town shows yeah I'll
promote them but I want to stay focused
on September 29th and 30th for shows at
the La Jolla Comedy Store recording my
album and I will get a code for free
tickets I've been told so stay tuned for
that you can do any stories on that with
a lot of story you know it's a lot of
[ __ ] you prior before - so come on out
and support the cause the Crabtree shot
calm for any and all crap fees related
information there are a lot of ways to
help the podcast some free ones that
apparently we're not allowed to mention
anymore
also the merch still on the site go get
your shirts get whatever you want over
there premium EPS are there as well and
make sure you follow the crab feast on
Facebook and Twitter if there's any
merch things that you guys want to see
or just yes up email us you know our
email crap fees podcast at gmail and if
things that you wants to bring back mugs
koozie stuff like that if you guys send
us suggestions we're going to make them
happen so let us know we got some great
sponsors this week
zip recruiter is back are you guys
hiring are you are you hiring do you
know where to post your job to find the
best candidates look the challenge of
finding great town and the importance of
finding great talent for a successful
business or paramount
we've put we put an ad out for an intern
we've got tons of stuff coming back to
us and you look when I worked at UPS
shut up UPS Baltimore primary whatever
new we used to have a motto called do it
right the first time and finding that
right person and having them do it right
the first time is what you need with zip
recruiter you can post your job to 100
plus job sites with just one click then
they're powerful technology efficiently
matches the right people to your job
better than anyone else that's why zip
recruiter is different unlike other job
sites zip recruiter doesn't depend on
candidates finding you it finds them in
fact over 80% of jobs posted on zip
recruiter get a qualified candidate in
just 24 hours that's one day no juggling
emails or calls to your office simply
screen rate manage candidates all in one
place with zip recruiters easy to use
dashboard take advance
gentlemen find out today why zip
recruiter has been used by businesses of
all sizes to find the most qualified job
candidates with immediate result and
right now our listeners can post jobs on
zip recruiter for free that's right free
you hear that you can do it for free and
go find the people you need for free
right now just go to zip recruiter comm
slash crab that zip recruiter comm slash
crab zip recruiter comm slash crab and
back again blue apron blue apron if you
guys haven't heard from us before it's
the number one fresh ingredient and
recipe delivery service in the country
what does that mean it means you go on
their website you pick out recipes of
food you want to eat they send it to
your house they work and make incredible
home cooking accessible to everyone I'm
going to go over a couple things that
they have coming up here's the deal -
they ship you the exact amount you need
so there's no way so you can order for
two or four for Kate and I we do two and
then we make separate for the kids but
when the kids get old you could totally
do for everything is sourced from
sub-state good lord
come on jay-z food is sourced
sustainably understand is developed in
partnership with the Monterey Bay
Aquarium Seafood Watch beef chicken and
pork come from responsibly raised
animals the whole they're doing a great
job over there for us we like to cook
together as a family when Kate and I are
working in the kitchen with the kids
it's just it's better for us it's better
for you too it's healthier
you know everything going you know
everything donated together it's and
they're not skimping on stuff like
coming up check out this chili butter
steaks with Parmesan potatoes and
spinach creamy shrimp rolls with quick
pickles and sweet potato wedges first of
all this is the other thing that I've
been learning is different ways to like
cook and prep food that I didn't know
like quick pickling stuff like wee quick
pickle onions to put on like sandwiches
or different meals that we get and we're
introduced to new like sometimes it's
like an Asian dish Moroccan dish
Ethiopia is all different styles and
food it's affordable for less than $10
per person per meal seasonal recipes
along with pre-portion greetings to make
delicious home-cooked meals variety like
I just said it's all different types of
cuisine and you get to pick it flexible
you just go on there like I want this I
want that boom easy each meal comes with
a step by step easy fall recipe cut and
pre-portioned greetings
can be repaired in 40 minutes or less
and then you know how to cook the meal
future going down the road check out
this week's menu and get your first
three meals free with free shipping by
going to blue apron dot-com
slash crab feast you'll love how good it
feels and tastes create incredible
home-cooked meals with blue apron so do
not wait that's blue apron calm slash
crab feast and remember three meals free
and free shipping why would you not try
it in Li free once and great free food
and talking about great ProFlowers is
back again I spontaneously surprised my
cousin I sent her some flowers why was
that and she found some rhymes
ah she was that uh she was completely
unexpected unexpected that was that is
that even real show some unexpected it
was completely unexpected and I felt
good about it she went nuts for it she
was so stoked I'm going to see her when
I go home introduced her to Stella and
all that good stuff on ProFlowers
surprised me sent me some farmstand
flowers a bouquet that was sent and
looked beautiful it had it was a summer
bouquet it had three in this humble gown
three sunflowers in it ton I mean it was
packed full of flowers and man they
drank a lot of water I'll tell you that
I did what I was supposed to do maintain
them cut them fresh under the water on
an angle put some food in them and let
me tell you they lasted three weeks
three weeks and I say that's in
uninspected that was definitely
unexpected predictability yes my man I'm
unexpected it looks as you can say what
you want to say predictability is boring
surprises are exciting ProFlowers makes
it easy for you to surprise someone
right now and it's making it even easier
with a special offer for our listeners
send ProFlowers is farm stand flowers
and get 20% off of this collection or
any of their other unique exclusive
bouquets of twenty nine dollars or more
proflowers.com makes choosing the
perfect surprise bouquet simple and
quick the flowers are guaranteed to stay
fresh for at least seven days or your
money back and I'm telling you we always
tell you they always last long is that
three weeks my did they lasted three
weeks you get to pick the exact date
your unexpected surprise will arrive
it ProFlowers gives you more bloom for
your buck big beautiful flowers with
more stems for your money to get 20% off
your farm stand flowers or any other
bouquet of twenty nine dollars or more
go to proflowers.com and use our code
crab CRA be it check out that's
proflowers.com and code crab don't wait
don't wait to make someone's day go
ahead and be unpredictable well I'll
tell you right now talking about
unpredictable if you ever watch if
you've ever watched this guy's show you
know this shows one of the funniest on
TV and the most unpredictable we're
stoked to have one of the nicest guests
we've ever had on the podcast ladies and
gentlemen please welcome mr. Sal Vulcano
now you can clap for ya I love that song
you guys have by the way yes you're a
song who is that and generated that's
our yeah unsolicited sent to us I gotta
get into it right away that song is
undeniable it's undeniably a son is
another serious he's great
you know I wanted to say is when we were
doing the rabbit-hole show with Rory you
came on the show yeah and I never ever
ever
I've only once smoked weed before going
on stage and that night someone was
there smoking weed you remember a bunch
of people smoking weed I remember I
didn't okay yeah where everyone was and
I'm like you know what let's just see
what happens let's see what hit on the
rabbit hole
go down the rabbit hole so I smoked a
ton with Rory we get on stage we're
doing our thing I'm having a blast and
I'm sitting there and every week Rory
always introduces the first guest and
I'm sitting there and I'm like is it
fall Connell is it volcano because you
were going first could you hit like five
spots together yeah and I'm sitting
there in my head on my wall
thank God it's on Rory you know because
I just didn't want I hate messing up an
intro yeah so sitting there and then
Rory goes Rory look so cos I J want you
introduce our first half and I just
stood behind the mic like just like I am
NOT gonna man go ahead you got it it's
like now I want you take this week I
always do why don't you do it well they
like want me I didn't hear like I'll
[ __ ] I did not want to offend Sal right
now you know but to me it was like you
know it was great too and uh do you
think Rory did it because he didn't know
how to dance but he's not saying in the
natural just do you think well I'll tell
you but
I'm sitting there like oh [ __ ] he
doesn't know Rory doesn't know either
things on me now I'm like just pick one
just pick one I'm like and I was like
you know what let him handle him like
nah man you got this and he introduced
you it was great we get offstage and he
looks at me he goes you didn't have
pronounce the last name did you
ha ha ha - no he goes I don't know
because I just had some feeling that you
didn't and I go dude I was panicking it
I didn't go dealing that's what yeah and
I go uh no I don't think so
Rory you know Rory's like such a great
improviser you know sometimes you're in
moments and use like you feel something
you don't that's what's going on right
now and they went for it so you know
what I mean they get I mean most of the
time people get wrong most yeah it's
somebody did last night I always thought
it was volcon oh yeah that's the other
that's the most popular
misinterpretation but I mean it really
who's to say what it is right I say
volcano but I mean but last night the
guy didn't even know at all and I won't
name names but uh I he gonna bear mile
walk so Jeremiah idea we live German
dunno heat in the home and this happens
all the time but he did that thing it's
like vintage sure he was like he did
like he said Sally held it so the clap
started yeah and over the clouds you and
I just said nothing totally it was so
far so obvious but it you know it's like
that movie you don't remember some of
the names so when you introduce your
girl you're like hey it's my wife Kate
and then you like look away you look
look over here hoping things like oh hey
what's that man about my life I mean I
don't happen to me a hundred thank God
me too I feel terrible every time I feel
terrible if I have a partner that I'm
like go up and introduce yourself yeah
yeah and then sometimes people don't say
their name back I'm like we didn't get
it we didn't yeah we don't have we don't
need it like I just it's a known thing
like I don't have to get everyone and
I'm the most mortifying thing ever which
has happened to me a few times in my
life and that's never recovered from it
it's calling someone the wrong name I'm
not being dramatic guys I've never
[ __ ] recovered from but it's like you
caught that is the most embarrassing I
did it recently like right to their face
oh yeah and she was like that's not me
that's what I was like and then when she
left everybody in the room was
chose her - I'm like I'm the one that
took the [ __ ] oh that's I all thought
it was hard to see whether I had a
meeting yesterday with two women
pitching a TV show and we're in there
and we're talking for like 15 minutes
right and I go well listen it's great to
meet you guys blah blah blah and I start
going in and the one woman goes yeah
we've met before I know we have weird
she goes here you came in to pitch last
year you don't remember and I was like I
kind of do she was like super cool but
like wow I was kind of in and out of the
meeting I'm like I'm like we good though
I just had to keep calling back and
making a joke of it yeah otherwise
well last year we're out there you know
it is the reverse I have that where we
meet fans and like so after live shows
we'll do meet and greets and stuff and
like fans will come to him be like the
same thing I look so nice I mean the
general rule I'm gonna say this one was
nice to meet you yeah and I get it you
know every fields what we met you'll end
up with a little bit of an atmosphere
with an addict I'm like all right I was
like well so good to see you again I'm
like you don't remember or whatever
they'll say so
mm because ya ll say something you don't
remember that show here you pass me in
my hole oh my god what means everything
yeah I forget them and I'm like please
don't be offended clearly you don't
they lead oh well I'll say this for in
your defense I watched we were in Vegas
together you guys were doing your show
and you came and did some shows at the
crapshoot festival and walking through
the casino you got stopped non stop it
with money so people lined up took
pictures and you you did for every
single person oh yeah of course yeah
yeah yeah yeah it was very so really bad
situation like well my dad I was my dad
means act if it has in the hallway I'll
be Bradley thank you tell remember ah oh
I have a gentleman or lumina I have a
general rule not to turn when people
shout at my face shout at me like I'm a
dog that they do that yes normally
before they'll be like no joke like two
blocks away not even above and they'd be
like yeah yeah and then I I used to used
to stop and turn I'd be like hey and
then they and then if I stop and turn
they go come here
like I'm gonna walk yeah yeah come over
here
you know or just like wait for the light
just you got it out of it so then I used
to be like Aria yeah then I used to just
be like I'll turn away but I won't break
stride and now I don't even look because
if someone shouting at me like a dog
from two blocks away that this date they
they have they don't really get what's
in tight like what what I I mean this
sounds like like Long Island or Staten
Island like around the neighborhood kind
of stuff
it ain't like bigoted look at volcano
over here not even [ __ ] say hey you
know I had a guy last time I was in LA
which is a couple months ago
I was walking my friend was going to get
lunch and I got stopped look it doesn't
it happens a lot sometimes sometimes
happens not at all it just depends on
the day and it's totally cool as long as
I was I'll get into this when someone
but people want to take pictures of me
in the ER with my dad in the stretcher
but uh okay that happened in Brooklyn
yeah and the guy was I had Doc can you
stop that real quick the guy was
literally JIT upset with me that I was
like dude this is my dad this is the ER
can I not take a photo with you in your
family right now whatever and he was
like come on man and I'm like put it's
my I'm like excuse me actually we were
in the middle of a round circle
discussion with doctors and he tapped me
on the shoulder I turn around he's like
yeah I love you shall we get a picture
in the middle and I just like I don't
know look if you don't do this you know
it's negative ad man this was Staten
Island but that for honestly I just
happened this happened everywhere
everywhere like I got to a car accident
once I was in my car traffic right his
red light car car car
I'm but stopping no traffic I'm on the
phone my dad all of a sudden boom I get
hit from behind like pretty hard my neck
like snaps I my dad i [ __ ] I just
because what happened was there was an
already an accident so that the cars
were pulled over and there was cop car
everyone's looky-loo
it was cop cars and ambulances so we
were right literally I was stopped next
to the cop cars and the ambulances so
they watched me get hit yeah so it
couldn't be more than me right this
older guy rerun me the cop they all saw
it so I was like dad I just guy hit me
in the back of Chloe right back so to
aid the ambulance drivers right at the
empty he goes I put the brakes I roll
down and he he walks around
and walks around a car I lower my window
I'm actually holding my neck he leans in
he goes yo can I get a picture with me
the first thing he said I go dude I go
I'm actually actually hopefully gonna
cook can I pull over we didn't get it
when I pull over like you guys chili so
what happened right he's like yeah so
how about when I'm late on the stretcher
you just deal that we get more together
man I need some [ __ ] butter around me
got it I get out right I pull over the
cops are there again I'm holding my neck
right he comes over to guy I talked to
the cops he comes over with this things
they want to take me to the to the
hospital yeah and I you have to choose
to waive it or not so you have to fill
out a sheet if you want to waive it he
comes over he's okay go he's like I
still got most of it has my name like
Staten Island on it New York he doesn't
have my exact address he saw every piece
information that he said that he knew
and I was like okay then he goes let me
ask you a question look I know your
necks all [ __ ] up and turn your left
ear even all right he goes can you do me
a favor personal favor
so okay what he was the lady in the
ambulance from the accident before she's
a huge fan oh my which was shouts
suspect to me right oh my god how does
he even know that right so where are you
at this point I mean you want to stretch
her or anything like right now I'm
standing on the side of the road near
now you waiving your right to go to the
hospital free I am free you are free
hold the Jersey route 33 I had to get to
my grandma's at my aunt's house even
with their neck like this
it wasn't like [ __ ] up like like it
was like I was worried but it it snapped
okay so I was like I'm just getting a
[ __ ] out of it it was just a traffic
there's no I'm going so for some
yachtsman give me an ice pack so he goes
can you do me a personal favor
he says personal favor of course so we
go so wet the way back he goes can you
lady in the ambulance is a dog fan of
yours it would mean the world if you
just went over and said how long he's
about to die yeah so I guess is this
appropriate like she's in the she's in
the stretch in the stretch around end of
believe you put it would be such a big
favor to me and I know she would love it
so I go all right when I'm done talking
to the cops I'll go over there
there's talking to the cops I welcome to
the ambulance emmalin's closed that
doors are closed so I'm like alright I
think of your light so I open it to door
as I swing him open she's in a stretcher
she's tied down she can only she can't
look she's looking straight up all they
ever like stabilized yeah so I associate
like I go excuse me and she's like she
looks guys she looks at me and she goes
yeah and I know I got excuse me before
she looks like oh excuse me uh and she
goes yes she's only looking straight up
and I go uh I was asked to come over and
say hello to you my name is Sal I'm on a
show called Impractical Jokers and she
goes and are they pranking she goes end
and I go yeah and then she looks up at
you because yes and I go that's it that
guy I appreciate her like I just good
night good luck see he didn't know who I
was at all which I don't understand what
the [ __ ] the guy was talking about she
didn't even know who I was she didn't
blink acknowledge it meanwhile he's
rifling through your glove box and [ __ ]
looking for memorabilia that pad you
don't think they were practical joking
hiking my little tiger practical joke I
know when that's happening this was not
that the guy was like overtly like he
was over the tops and see like I don't
know what I don't know he was a lunatic
I don't know why he would say that but
she did not know me at all
yeah well now I feel again this is it
sounds like a good time to let people
know where they can find your in social
media like that we've been talking yeah
we need to do that right away I don't
want to stop you but yeah please your
social media your show pot whatever
anything yet yeah I like I guess what
Twitter Instagram is just at Sal Vulcano
my name what else the shows on Thursdays
of 10 I haven't gained all the time
we signed for seven it's on I don't all
just turned it on I'm sorry gentleman
Network we are we have a cruise November
1st to the 5th for our fans out of New
Orleans to Mexico a sick is that
you know the first time you've done that
or you don't have before it's the second
one now and how's the first one out of
control I'm world kill imagine 20 of my
cup comedian friends we are
the band VG's I bought like 30 of my
family members Oh like yeah like it's
like 2:00 in the morning
we're on stage it's a dance party
karaokes on people are stage-diving I
looked at 11:00 and Stanhope's like
grinding at my mom Crist Erica all my
world Cologne and how many how long is
the cruise it's a four nine five days
really great and how many shows you guys
do we do three and so everybody's on the
cruise gets to come to a show tech
ticketed out and then there's like tons
of other shows like never Elvis band the
best one in the world that hey one that
we have like a Yacht rock band oh yeah
yeah my favorite that 80s yes so it's
like a real party like that one right
man yeah I mean talking about not being
able to get away from your fans your
goddamn cruise ship but I know that none
of those piata is you just got to let it
go with the door you check-in and it's
about they made to be they're just part
of it yeah it's fun it's crazy that one
on this cruise I got neck brace wouldn't
even look at me we got we got a big show
in LA on September 24 for playing the
Greek so yeah that's cute I'll plug that
because I hope be great weather like out
there a that oh man I've never been I
saw pictures oh it's pretty beautiful
yeah yeah very till it's in the [ __ ]
mountain like you know the Griffith Park
mountains but there's a little nine hole
golf course over there that I'll play
once in a while yeah and depending on
the day during sound check you can hear
sound check on the golf course it's like
my favorite course just for that reason
alone I mean that's on the ads don't
what a cool spot and it's oh and then
one other one solo I'm playing the House
of Blues on July 20th in San Diego
during comic-con and that's really till
I got they'll be great that's all I know
that's a lot man good for you are you
guys going to be a cluster first yeah
yeah is I'm not oh I thought I saw [ __ ]
okay usually I'll be at school looking
at yeah all right I remember what do you
guys get into it ice what's up well I I
told you before like I I'm such a huge
fan of yours and the show like thank you
I stumbled onto it or like your first
season and I was like oh my god this is
[ __ ] hilarious and I remember I was
back in Baltimore visiting relatives it
was late I was like put trutv on real
quick let's see if this shows on
and it's on my cousin i sat there we
just [ __ ] laughed and lag and it
looks like so much fun if I have notes
on the show my buddies we can do that
you know but I get I get anxiety
watching like oh my god I can do that
like what I asked you before but what's
something that you were just like I'm
not definitely not doing that um we have
this thing where it's tough not to do
much like in the moment we could say no
you know the way that shows me that you
can say no but if you say no you're
probably going to lose the episode and
you can't say no to a punishment nor 90%
of punishments do you know what they are
right until they have so we made a pact
with each other that we can't back out
on a punishment so those days are
actually very very stressful and tense
filled because you you don't know what's
going to go on and you know that you're
not allowed to say no so there's been
things that I had to do because of that
circumstance if I would have never done
in my [ __ ] life like jump out of a
helicopter or dig through relevant [ __ ]
or get a tattoo of Jaden Smith or be
putting a swamp in the [ __ ] value I'm
like I'm kind of a germ guy I don't have
a good immune system and they don't have
got a gazelle listen man lighting
systems is a 20% they dressed me up with
like this swamp monster and I had to
hide under the water like up to my chin
might be scared of alligators alligators
you know there's a leghe's it's a
[ __ ] body design yeah or the people
who ran the [ __ ] it was like a fan
boat area place and oh yeah they don't
come through here oh my god any land
like I'm not put world yes I say I'm
throwing on the back of that like right
one might just not go come on they're
out there I'm like okay so one's not
gonna [ __ ] meanwhile they got a
[ __ ] remote-control alligator I
didn't know and drove it told me at well
I would have [ __ ] myself I was worried
about the parasites going in my pee hole
so I put I actually wore it all I got
you have as far as I had to get it up
yeah yeah pull bone in the whole time I
know guys adventure sex with prostitutes
economy got one on the [ __ ] swamp
I heard they go in there and then also
they start eating from the install my
god
sit out which might not a bad thing for
me yeah yeah you've been actually
working out nah man [ __ ] paddy home on
that new parasite day so you always like
that as a kid growing up were you always
like a prankster like Jay loves to do
that [ __ ]
were you always someone that would
[ __ ] with people or I would say yeah I
mean we might say all-boys Catholic High
School there's not much to do that with
that we mainly reflux around a lot of
stuff we do on the show it's literally
lifted from stuff we did in the past you
all go back that far together 27 well we
met his freshman in high school 1990
that's [ __ ] all I'll graduated same
year yeah wait I'm gonna be in your 91 I
graduated 91 no I'm not we graduated 94
94 now yeah Obama twice so you guys been
doing that kind of [ __ ] a long time
pretty much and we had so many like
failed scripted things and like what can
we do we just like something to do we
just could make not script anything just
be us like just be us and that was what
was born of it yeah that's all I love it
I mean you have so many of these stories
here growing up I want to hear about I
don't hear about this basement apartment
you don't talk about that yeah my he
said I used to live in this little
little [ __ ] studio basement apartment
alone I was bartending so I would sleep
till like 4:00 or 5:00 in the afternoon
yeah I know the odd bartender for a long
time yeah there's other people who don't
bartend think that's unreasonable but I
get home 5:00 in the morning I worn down
so I'm [ __ ] passed out I got the it's
pitch black and I hear someone pounding
at my toe like a boy buy me like really
pounding and I jump up out of a dead
sleep its pitch black I'm like hello and
I hear shouts
Dan open the door hurry up and Dan was
he looked upstairs my landlord
New York City detective big big Irish
guy so I stumbled a do i crack it open
the Sun comes in like what's going on
he's [ __ ] he's his face is beat ready
sweaty because I just got hold someone
my door upstairs is off the hinges some
broke into the house and they probably
they might be still in there let's go
let's go right I I have no training at
all I don't know
so yeah I'm [ __ ] 10 seconds I'm fresh
out of a Reb cycle I'm in Corona pajamas
I got the drool I get everything and got
Corona night pants
come on an iPad and then he was so like
what do you do in that situation I can't
look at him be like yeah now you know
yeah so I was just like I I was so
overwhelmed I didn't know my I didn't
even my head you know my faculties so I
probably I put on a robe cut around dogs
without my robe and I follow him and we
go to the front doors off the hinges
crack hanging off the hinges which is
[ __ ] nuts
I mean no one breaks into a home like
that I know I never saw that personal
it's [ __ ] popped off the top and like
hanging off like they just battered it
in and he pulls out a [ __ ] gun and
[ __ ] it yeah I tell the story on so
many stories I fell on stage but yeah
out of this but I never had had never
seen a gun in my life before now this
guy pulls out a gun [ __ ] it and he
looks at me in collisions I'm gonna go
in I'm gonna I'm gonna go around the
house I look at the perimeter he's like
using terms like basics I'm just gonna
get the perimeter because I wanna secure
a perimeter because you get my back and
I visit with what this is what I said to
him I said this day when I in the moment
as it was coming out of the why the [ __ ]
am i toggle yes I was like I'm a guy I
big guy like cuz I live down
holding my role I was literally holding
my robe like this already it sounds like
I'm the guy in the guy got Charla's of
your hair and he goes in and he's
looking like in the movies yeah you
don't they like the very technical
approach of a cop when he's going down a
hole checking in and out of doors he's
doing that I'm like oh my god I'm behind
him I got nothing I'm in a robe I had no
weapon he didn't give me like a bat my
friend Johnny gharana night right so
yeah like I didn't know what to put my
hand in my pocket like a [ __ ] fake
gun I mean I was trying to do a road
whenever I could do to contribute yeah
like and just like you know like you
ever see see no evil evil with Jean wire
and Richard Pryor I'm but yeah there's a
scene which you know how that comes out
of there's a girl like in the shower or
something like that and he comes into a
room and she comes out of the shower and
he puts his hand in his pocket to make
believe he has a gun and he pointed out
he's a guy everybody just calm down
move away he said he's like everything's
gonna be okay just step away he kept his
pocket and still there he gets a hard-on
during it so the same exact same exact
you know his fingers it's such a funny
scene he pulls it out and it's still
there in the anyway so we go up so
there's no one on the first floor second
floor so going up to the steps he's it
going up he's got the gun and he looks
at music yeah so give it an see stuff to
enhance it right up after the topics of
this one door right in the toxically and
he's not talking he's hoping like he'll
serve eyes up oh yeah I'm guessing your
whole like he'll survive nah he was
right it was haha all wet I should tell
you the look in his eyes I've never seen
it before since he's you're hired at
this point as he's now he's active at
that point he was on the call yeah yes
his car like if I can't call for backup
if he wants this [ __ ] he he has a look
and you know you don't come across
people look he's he's ready to shoot
somebody's in his house it's them on him
yeah I you don't see that look in
people's eyes - uh-huh
and it's really [ __ ] scary because
I'm like it's what the robber has a gun
but anything you go wrong right now and
I'm thinking like this legit this looks
JIT we always think you always have that
thought like some guys how will I die
when will
and I'm like I'm a [ __ ] die
protecting this guy's [ __ ] CDs what is
what has worked this for me to be
involved here like if someone's in the
house
step out call somebody yeah I don't need
backup I got my tenant in a row but not
basically what is my function at this
point if they start fighting and the
guns go like what is my exact function I
don't know I guess it's just good to
have another body but anyway we don't
know what to expect so he starts going
this and he's doing like these subtle
gestures like I was in [ __ ] are
rotating afraid I don't know and her
hand and he's like this and I'm like I'm
looking at him and I go and I just shake
yes and he kicks the [ __ ] door and he
kicks the door and goes in when his
gonna come he's good
I just I yell out oh my god I just show
that oh my god and there was nobody in
there and he turned around he was like
he just looked at me like man you just
[ __ ] lost it for a second but when he
kicked the door in
but he didn't tell me he's gonna do that
he did a couple of gentle hand signals
and then he kicked it in I was like oh
my god I didn't know what was gonna
happen on stage I say on stage I say
that I yelled oh my god pow pow I got
I'm like I made the sound of a gunshot a
cartoon but yeah that was always so
that's whatever then all of a sudden all
of these cops flood the place because
he's a detective
yeah he called them prior to getting me
so they came in it was like 10 cars
screeching up they all run in I mean
guns [ __ ] drawn they run up the steps
and like what he said I did they start
talking everything everything's real
[ __ ] intense and they talked him for
a minute and they turn to me and they
stop [ __ ] grilling me because they're
like see the counts like so how is it he
goes let me answer this I mean well I'm
his friend I just rest of my life yeah
all of a sudden I'm the number-one
suspect apparent because I was the only
one home so the cop turned to me he's
like let me ask a question how is it
that you were home and the doors off the
hinges up here and you didn't hear
anything
and I was like whoa I was sleeping and
he goes sleeping he's like it's 4
o'clock in the afternoon and I'm like
I'm a bartender I might not have been
the best life choice not like guilty
telling him right what why I'm sure why
I'm asleep at 4:00 in the afternoon and
they're all just looking at me no you
were sleeping
I'm not yet look I don't know what you
want me to say like I bartend I sleep
late you know what I mean but they like
grilled me and made me feel bad about my
life and then I went back downstairs and
that was it but I was gonna die not even
funny it's like he was like you guys he
cleared the house and he's like I man
and then you walking out and then they
show up like thank you out yeah yeah I
was talking I mean that was the only
time I've ever seen like a look at
someone be ready to use a loaded gun
yeah different my face but I was amazed
I hope you guys have any experience like
with that kind of [ __ ] but a guy would
make fun of me about that how I handle
that but I'll callus do you handle it
you handle the exact I mean actually
please tell me you shouldn't have gone
be like I'm gonna win now here right now
and then I'm not trained I know I had a
so I don't want to stay in my house
alone
if he was up there with a gun maybe that
guy had his hiding out in was your place
connected to hid out wasn't connected it
was illegal to family I could say that
now this is a 2000 year the year 2000 I
think so
17 years like that's the first time I've
said that out loud I was told not to say
that goodbye him
no no I like far away he was a good
friend actually so I said this kid's
clear he wasn't part of the Burleigh but
we do have tenants and whoever the
state's here to investigate the living
situation term you know know you have so
many [ __ ] stories here I can't even
yeah I don't know where you want to go I
gotta be ripping these and not waiting
for silence and you to prompt me to do
it I'll do however you want to yeah yeah
along no I want to hear I mean if you
don't I'll just we'll just start picking
what we want to hear but I want to hear
about Bubba ray Dudley oh you guys you
guys wrestling fans roar now I was but I
don't know who Bubba ray Dudley is Bubba
ray Dudley's part of the Dudley Boyz
even though the 20-plus years they
they were like the WUF for everybody he
started an ECW which was that one where
they started put like each other on fire
and Jess this guy is huge
he's you know six foot I don't know what
five he's probably 300 pounds and he's
been that they just they just retired
but they were in the double J's like 25
years they were tag-team champs they
were like literally the baddest of
badasses and they started in ECW ECW
around mmm 99 2000 was this extreme
wrestling that started it was born out
of maybe like the backyard wrestling and
these guys would like throw tax down and
slam each other into the tacks
throw each other through light the
tables on fire that was their big thing
dudley boyz they did the table something
they would put I get the ladder fluid I
am lighter fluid lighting on fire so
those [ __ ] people threw the thing
they get lit on fire I mean they would
hit each other with [ __ ] bottles
everything was a bloody mess it was like
it was like this new wave of violence
and everybody was way into it and I
think that that that would bring a
certain crowd to see oh yeah you think
that yeah people that was [ __ ] brawl
listen I'm no expert but so like this
they got this refugee badge in the
parking lot after those like an event
they were constantly brawls full-on
girls an arrest a to every show yeah and
that was the reputation it had because
people were like they would come and
they would antagonize them and they
didn't take any [ __ ] from anybody these
guys had a rough show on Staten Island
right this is before he blew up and they
went to the data show on Sandow and he
gets in people's faces all part of the
thing but then some guy spit on him he
said a full-on stadium wide brawl cops
everything they all get arrested so this
is the reputation that they have that
extinct I don't [ __ ] around like say
what you want about wrestling but he was
in like a brawl every show like
literally lighting up people I didn't
know this that's an important part of
that might be the vote that time I I
like wrestling as a kid but at that time
when I was like whatever I was 20 years
old I fell out of it yeah okay but I had
a beach house with my friends down in
Belmar New Jersey
and and in majoras rented for the summer
yeah yeah and they all loved wrestling
so there was going to be a wrestling
event in in that beach town and they're
all going someone I'll go with you guys
it's gonna be good I haven't seen
wrestling a long time whatever and this
was during this ECW again that's where I
fell out too like right after right
before like Shawn Michaels yes that's
exactly when I thought that's when I
fell yeah I'm back into it now again
that's a difference are but anyway so I
go with them and it's a it's like a 95
degree day and the place it's called bar
anticipation and inside they have a big
outdoor patio with like volleyball coach
that's where the ring is set up and
everybody hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of people waiting and getting
didn't open how many does it hold it the
place I want to say a few hundred okay
okay so they're all waiting in a line we
are all waiting in a line outside the
venue 95 degree weather will they a
half-hour waiting for them to open the
doors along a line of 100 people the
parking lot is that capacity to one of
those things where they they parked cars
a row and then right behind them and
right behind them so no one's getting
out they just no wiggle room we have to
go to this row out that narrow so
there's no room in the parking lot a
couple hundred people lined up he pulls
up in a car and across the other end of
the parking lot little Honda Civic and
get that once though he gets out this
guy is [ __ ] huge right he gets out of
the car at a 99 either it's his night no
this is 1999 el-nana is it 99 yeah I
know
it said he gets out of the car and
there's a little smattering of applause
wrestling fans whatever they fall silent
and for some reason I was just like oh
I'm gonna be part of the wrestling I was
like hey Bubba ray Dudley you fat [ __ ] I
said that that's not even cross my
character at all yeah I don't talk like
that I don't I don't know why I said it
I didn't know nothing about I he didn't
I just antagonizing his man for no
reason I don't forget a laugh I don't
even like I'm not giving you sons of
[ __ ]
yeah so I say that and I just kind of
turn and my friend Jeff goes he I see my
friends face go pale he goes pale
immediately and he goes and I'm and now
I have my back
because I didn't want to like be like it
was you know yeah I just said it I
figure I'm in I'm in a crowd
he's faceless failure Sal he's coming
over he god I go yeah okay right right
Jeff I go how would even know who said
it you go Sal he is coming over here and
he is charging us and he goes he is are
hopping over the cars yes I I don't like
is running over loose running over the
hood he's running over the whole place
is like extra whatever they were jumping
over so I turned slightly cuz I don't
want to give him that it was me I turned
to me out of my progress I see him
[ __ ] slide over hood like a [ __ ] it
like like a good boy yeah I'm like
almost like all right cool cool guys
guys good I was with 14 of my friends yo
guy there's no way he's gonna know who
did it
it's also just say stay calm stay calm
and at that moment I turn around and
there was stanchions with metal chains
and he he got up to this line with a
stanchion throw the man he took the
chain and he ripped a metal chain out of
the stanchion Catullus using your
gravity like that to chamber a metal
chain popped off and he walked right up
to me oh I'm glad to be in the face now
my god he came out he took my hat at a
Yankee hat on he took my security guards
started my own man widely-known flanking
him I don't know like exactly what they
thought they're gonna do or what he was
a-doing what I was into he took my
Yankee out of my face and full swung
slapped me with it and and it dropped to
the floor news you got something to say
you want shakes up my [ __ ] face now
hi you're a tough guy you're a tough guy
and I wouldn't let the one thing I said
during so don't look up don't look him
in the eyes don't look him in the face
he had the veins coming out of his neck
I knew that if he if he swung he would
knock my head off my shoulders was that
hard to tell you but you never put the
current pocket Civic so I mean 400
people a day online
pin drop everyone is dead [ __ ] silent
dead silent and he's right and he's
breathing he's he you could tell that
like he's on the precipice of losing
control and taking a swing without what
and nothing is through that's where he
was at and I'm like if I even put
pull my hands up even like to here and
give any motion I don't want to
instigate him so I keep my hands down at
my sides like this
I won't look him in the face he's right
of a dick say it again say it right now
to my face so I turned into like Rain
Man right I was looking down I'm like
look I'm just a big fan I'm just a big
fan of wrestling I don't know what to
tell you I'm just I'm just trying to be
part of the challenge is I really do
Santa but I kept on saying really big
fan I said like 15 times in 10 seconds I
was really big fan just gonna be famous
listen and he's like anybody wouldn't
back off so he's getting in my face
again and my friend Eddie I see him I
see these security guards were in yellow
security our jackets and I see him
pushing physically pushing the security
guard in between the two of us to like
get the security to do something and I
see the security guard pushing back
cause if you're in love doesn't want to
get in the middle of it and I see he's
literally pushing his body and the
sugars leaning back into him to not get
pushed in the middle of us and he I go
to pick up my hat and I stole it and he
takes it he slaps me with it again and
then he decorated one it was a fitted
cupcake thank God is a snapback that
could be black in a hurry yeah so he's
like I [ __ ] talk so he's like [ __ ]
you whatever it was probably 20 seconds
total felt like you know now he turns
around and walks away right as I was
dude
I as he walked away he is getting to the
door as soon as you walk so he's getting
to the door and the [ __ ] crowd he
rocks like like gangbusters like
cheering you think they thought it was
part of the show no ok just cheering him
on because I was an [ __ ] fan they put
me in my place and they saw some
real-deal [ __ ] so they [ __ ] explode
cheering him now I feel even worse right
because now I did something that was
like out of character for no reason I
felt bad about that then I thought he
was gonna kill me I look like an [ __ ]
and now he made me look like a big guy
so I was a little [ __ ] yeah none I mean
and so they're all cheering and now I'm
really embarrassed and I'm like how do I
so I could save face here so he I wait
til he gets in the door the the cheering
stops and I I lit I smoked it on my
little cigarette my hands my hand was
involuntary to go
right I lit it up I take a drag I step
out of the line and I go anybody else
got a problem and the whole the whole
place went up and then they lined up and
I was signing program shut up [ __ ] coma
and I wonder I'm actually hilarious yeah
good for you like the guy in jail who
wins the respect back by being funny you
know what I mean
dude I pulled that out of my ass it was
the only thing I could have said they
were almost I go that was so far they
were on board with it but also to this
day though so now he's in WWE and I get
back into it I got some tickets I
started going again it turns out a lot
of the rest was on the road my shows on
all the time there's a lot of rest of
the fans of ours and it ends up being
that he I get introduced to him he
doesn't realize Who I am I told my story
he remembers it he does yeah and since
then actually become good friends he
comes out to my shows all of that well
like with legit friends it is so leader
he's really the skin should like write
him you should like do some sketches
with him like set up or like you a fan
heckling you like oh really and then he
comes up on stage and you [ __ ] like I
don't know I either way I mean does he
remember sliding over the hoods and all
this [ __ ] coming after you now he
remembers that day and a fan [ __ ]
would have been even [ __ ] the guys I
laugh and when you retell it you know he
doesn't really dunno how I bet he's like
well I remember in San Jose I killed
again you guys it was a drop in the
bucket yeah you gotta lug you but yeah
but uh but the guys set me up with the
guys and I tour and we do our own
materials together and we've recorded
two of our tours so when we recorded our
first hour we backstage waiting to go on
the first time we've ever recording
anything like this live on stage and he
came and I didn't know when they kept in
a secret and like we were sitting back
maybe 10 minutes before showtime and
they turned on the cameras I wasn't
paying attention
and he [ __ ] kicked the door and he
walks he goes where the [ __ ] is Sal any
what he comes in like screaming and I
hadn't seen him before I only saw him
once before that and he came from the
great when he grabbed my shirt I just
had a crack enough in it but they did
that to me they met Adam come in Georgia
came via
David six five three I mean is he yoke
too
he's a big dude he said he's on
[ __ ] tree trunk yeah man he is so
intimidating and he was known for being
a badass you know what I mean yeah come
on why I said you know it's those it's
those moments when you have something
you had but you like I don't say this
but your your brain can't catch up to
your mouth and your mouth like why are
you saying this but you keep saying it
anyway yeah absolutely
you would you said we were talking
earlier about did you said you know you
got high on stage for the first time the
night that image it yeah yeah no honey I
don't twice in my life I've gotten high
moments before I stepped on stage new to
2010 and one time Rory Scovel common
denominator right there at the Virgil
yeah right before I don't do that he's
identified it was the worst experience
of my life one time I I both times rack
sentence one time I acted
I ate apple pie day it was on my sunset
of the shoot and I we had a post shoot
meeting and I wasn't around I saw an
apple plus I ate a slice at apply and
then after I'm done I'm on the less I
can bite cues like where'd you get that
I'm I goes over then I just snap upon
he's like dude [ __ ] are one of our
workers poured in a slice for everybody
its edibles and I was like on the whole
slice he liked it it was 100 milligrams
for the [ __ ] hospital like this oh my
[ __ ] god how much was that she goes a
hundred
I don't know weed I found out that I
mean I don't know what that is so 15 is
like enough 15 I took a hundred so I
start [ __ ] super panicking I had a
show I'd calmly juice at night at Gotham
and they promote it I didn't want to
miss it this was like one o'clock juice
was like I had to be there like 10:45
p.m. yeah so much oh my god what am I
gonna do I can't I can't get through
this high I can't so they they put me in
a car they had someone drive me home I
went right to bed I slept from like - to
like 9 p.m. I slept through it I woke up
at 9 [ __ ] so - seven hours later I
had a friend drive me to Gotham I get to
Gotham I said I'm so I told what
happened I'm like I don't want to miss
the show I said but if I [ __ ] up bad so
so I'm so hard right now and I could and
they're like okay giggles can
I lay down and like all right so they
put me in a booth and I like I'm like
can you just wake me up the right before
I go so they go okay so I lay down I'm
trying to just lose it you know I need
taps music you're up next oh my god I go
I woke up on stage and I'm just like
look 11 hours ago
eleventy took 100 milligram slice of
apple pie weed I was like I'm so high I
don't know what's going on and they just
they were in tears and I didn't have to
do material I was like just talking
through Hoggett soothing I loved it yeah
yeah and that's what I I hated the
ceiling oh wait - everyone's looking at
you judging you don't know what to say
you like what we don't want you don't
know if it's wrong if you're having oh
man works but so we'd I don't really do
a lot of like drugs I've done marijuana
recently I went to we were touring
Europe I went to Amsterdam for a couple
days for vacation so I'm with a couple
friends and we stumble upon the symphony
the answer dance Symphony starring Rufus
Wainwright really yeah do you know that
I do yeah okay so I vaguely knew that
what I didn't know I wouldn't picture
him in a symphony setting I didn't know
much about him I just knew that he was
like some really good like singer that's
probably like not on the radio but like
some really like prolific singer or some
like I didn't know anything laying
around la years ago in that first movie
I'd go watch him a lot
oh yeah yeah oh he's writing amazing so
what my friend and I were like oh [ __ ]
like why don't we this is the sign let's
just we walk up she says it sold out if
you wait until right before showtime
sometimes ticket oh but I'm alright
we'll wait so she calls back up she goes
to opened up right in the orchestra and
we're like holy dismal it's a [ __ ]
sign so we get it - it's right in the
[ __ ] right on our left aisle right in
the [ __ ] front and we say all right
show us on since five minutes we're in
Amsterdam
why don't we quickly go by like a joint
will smoke it or watch this [ __ ]
Rufus Wainwright Symphony hi it'll be
great fun runs it yet it comes back we
light it I take two really big pulls
hand it back to him and immediately I
sense something's different
I'm like what this is like even within
one minute I just feel like you're back
you know one minute within one minute we
didn't walk in yet I was going numb on
me and we walk in and I'm actually you
know like like heroin addicts walk like
that hobble I guess that dov'è hobble
I'm already doing that on the way and
she looked at my friend up yeah shuffle
oh my god something don't feel right and
she only took like two little heads and
I took this huge shift and she took not
it's okay and then they like immediately
everything was weird like they walk up
to us and they gave us hot wine hot wine
yeah which I never had before so that
was like I was like what is this [ __ ]
hot one what's going on here like
including tiny boy again poison me an
object like Game of Thrones
yes point so we get into we get to watch
here I sit and I know that once I sit
I'm like oh my god like I can no longer
move I'm frozen so the place is gorgeous
people are dressed up people are some
people are in tuxes like it's like
really gorgeous it's unbelievable and
and it's about to start
and I earn to my friend my god I'm
telling you something is wrong I've
never felt this way before in my life
i I don't know this feeling it's a
fallen feeling I just don't know where
you stop he took to it tomorrow who
cares you know and I go good night right
here I go like this okay I'm gonna leave
and she's like why and I literally dead
serious and can I tell you I believe
this with all my heart and it was the
most frightening it probably was the
most frightening moment of my entire
life more than the gun well anything
because I didn't have control of my mind
and I turned to him I go because
everybody in here is trying to kill me
everybody look at me like everybody here
right now is got to turn around at the
exact same time and try to kill me I
should have not sticking around for it I
should not say your and that right then
it started this is yeah right well right
then which vivid dramatic you know the
dramatic music oh this [ __ ] harps
violins they're all up there right it's
unbelievable and it starts and I and I
literally nearly go look at me I am
looking at the path to get out now I
know I'm everything's known I know I
don't really have my balance I know if I
get up I know if I get up I'm probably
going to stumble probably going to fall
and there's lady and we
chair in the aisle and it's taken up
like most of the aisle like if you had
your faculties you would have to buy
spurs your shimmy yeah and I know I'm
not getting by and I go let me tell you
something out I'm I said I'm gonna get
up right now and I'm actually gonna
scream I'm gonna scream on the way out
because I wanted to be no-nonsense I
wanted everyone to know don't mess with
me I just want to scalp me love me ah
and just charge the door just maybe
scare somebody
I just want to get killed and I was like
the lady in the [ __ ] wheelchair I'm
not going to get by her I'm telling you
right now cuz you're my friend I'm
helping her out I thought I said it's
gonna be real heart-stopper to me I'm
talking to me I'm frantic I'm frantic I
said you've lived earlier yeah and then
smoking like violence were you [ __ ]
huh exactly me I said I'm gonna try to
avoid it but if I have to take her out
and taking around and she's a just
continental drones or going and [ __ ] now
yeah think about what's going on her
mind or he's alright you look at me she
goes look at me look at me look at me I
think she was you're okay you're gonna
be okay gonna be okay I'm like no I'm
not right so then I stayed put and what
started happening was I started
hallucinating right and I was i
hallucinating that i was i gross out of
my chair and I was hovering above the
[ __ ] centrally looking down in
everybody and I was it was beautiful
like I was like an angel
and it started flips Lara and hold on I
love it I was like an angel like I was
know like I love everybody and the music
that was playing it just felt like
angelic and I'm like I started like
getting tears my eyes how beautiful it
was
and it kept flip-flopping from it this
is the most beautiful thing I've ever
seen because his voice right and and
then back to I'm gonna everyone's gonna
kill me so I was like fighting like
these these weird swing of emotions what
was the best night of my life in the
worst night of my life and my thoughts
I'd love you ever taken anything we do
you lose it like yes but my thoughts are
coming way way faster than I can
interpret them it was like a really
weird feeling really drowning in my own
thoughts and then he's done with the
first song and I don't know if you know
anything about Rufus where I didn't I
thought he was like an old guy like just
some old opera singer that's what I
thought
this guy's like 35 yeah and he's got
like like long hair and he
finishes the first song what came out of
his mouth was like a [ __ ] opera and
then he goes hey sir damn what's up
that's what he said and I turned my
ankle a my [ __ ] eye my [ __ ] [ __ ]
sorry a little piece young gay man is he
completely day and she goes no he is I
go what the [ __ ] is going on but it was
an old opera singer and he was like so
and he's like talking about I'm just
freaking the [ __ ] out and then I'm
getting dry mouth the hot wine is gone
long gone like I thought I like I can't
announce talking almost not able to
swirl close oh yeah I know that feel she
said I was sick so Sheila Schmidt
lozenges and you back get along it's all
like good idea so I will get a fanny
pack I looked at I had my backpack on
the floor I look down on my backpack and
for like 10 minutes like I'm gonna get
to this back I'm just staring down to do
my legs for 10 minutes I'm like I see
the backpack how do I get the backpack
and then I finally I'm not kidding my 10
minutes finally I just like slowly reach
down I opened the backpack I get a call
for a pad it's individually wrapped it
was a coldie so it wasn't like like a
whole suite on twirl it was like you
have to like the real the plastic it and
I just look at my grant the cole crops
in this how am I gonna get out of this
oh yeah and then I finally just uh I rip
it open and I feel like the crackle from
the wrapper literally is ten times
louder than that than the PA system
yeah and I just like oh my god again so
no so I just pop it in my mouth then I
turned her and I go and she's like whoa
everybody's upset with me and she's like
why I'm like all this noise and she's
like dude and then it was like a two and
a half hours thing we went out and we
left I was so happy to leave and then we
went to dinner I took the [ __ ] weight
it was gonna kill me and we're not Mike
he's coming over here way too [ __ ]
much somewhat of a way too much what's
he got to hide what's heat with you and
she's like he's he's always with you me
buds yeah and she tells me so I'm like
I'm not I'm insisting something's wrong
the whole time she told me no then she
goes oh she goes um it wasn't weed
though it was like it's likely this hand
and I was a [ __ ] hash hash is like
not weed hash are that oil in it that
makes you hallucinate and I took like I
don't know if you guys know about hash
I've smelt ash but I've never
hallucinate well this was [ __ ]
hallucinogenic lamb something like that
was symphony way it hit me and peanut
sounds and I I never I will never ever
ever ever go near anything like that
again it was the worst feeling all day
who else would want to go near that is
whoever's with you yeah because I have
been though she must because like she
was been on edge thinking like oh my god
any moment Sal's gonna like freak I I
promise you I really thought I was going
to come in I really was going to bowl
this [ __ ] lady in the wheelchair over
and just get the [ __ ] out of it was it
was it was [ __ ] up I'd every buddy I was
like their drugs are totally my only big
big drugs yeah I'm doing a lot how long
were you over there in Amsterdam yeah
three or four days that's awesome yeah I
don't know I didn't see you although I
didn't feel like but until like the
prosecutor in the windows in a lunch yet
but this sounds like even there's just
tons of art and a city is eautiful a
little it is that's what people forget
is there you know it went to go exact
sick art yeah it's good on I would
believe me I'm big with art and it was
great on more bikes and an sedan than
people right yes of yeah happy right I
know some space why are you - yeah it
was dope - I was either in Christmas I
professed a long main festival of lights
they call I'm a big Christmas guy big
yellow Christmas the wait you were there
on Christmas I would say like right
after like the first we could we you
home for Christmas yeah yeah cuz you
seem like a dude that is home for all
all of it dude I'm the guy that dresses
up as Santa for my niece's are you
really ever yet shake him awake him up
and I go to the front door they come out
groggy now and I close the door guys
okay I keep my distance and then you
split yeah I recently found out the
other second-youngest doesn't believe
anymore but didn't let on to it because
she wanted to protect me how old is she
11 one of the press you that's great
yeah it's so funny cuz like I'm older
I'm doing it for her yeah somewhere
along the line something switch and I
didn't even know she's doing it for me I
don't I mean yeah that's sweet
I'm playing with the crispy that's
already sound really likes it
I'll keep doing it that's it until my
friends accidentally threw the [ __ ] I
spent 300 bucks on a deluxe Santa suit
it was like crushed velour
it was the dopest [ __ ] ever it was like
the highest and when they sold like six
versions I bought the highest-end one I
let my friend borrow to do it to his
nieces he brought it back he put on the
side of my house in a garbage bag and my
Leland threw it away ah I never bought
it again I was the end of Santa thought
that yes do you thinking he I don't know
what he was thinking I'm gonna leave it
over here for you you put in the bag and
then my melon was garbage so like that
was two years ago Zola flashy my
youngest knees was like he didn't he
didn't stop this legit
I might know he was he just have to go
right away yeah you said about quick
know what else you guys I could pick
anything else yeah hell yeah I just -
like self-aware I'm like let me pick a
story on now let me take one for for
once over here now like that you know
it's funny I want to see this this in
fifth grade because one time when I was
in fifth grade maybe it's like what
you're going through that time but we in
music class we had to walk like an
Egyptian was huge so we were doing this
thing in in music class with like
everyone had to go around do like the
little Egyptian walk and my teachers
like rij and I'm like now I'm good and
she's like not everyone's gonna do it
I'm like oh yeah well my constitutional
right to choose and I said that not to
do the really rough she's like I call
the principal down mr. grant was like
get out there do the jib and I did he
like I'm not going to
culturally-appropriate you just I don't
know what I was like no [ __ ] that I got
a choice and this is my choice yeah we
were uh we were just it was dead silence
of grade we had AB we were doing an
assignment I rorty's were just writing
in their books and I had an epiphany and
I raised my hand miss demersal teacher
my reason she's like yeah these kids
want to kill me I'm not going to get
around that's my favorite line I've got
to take it around I'm taking out two in
the wheel chain but it will it kill me
I'm not around
why would I do that now I raise my hand
- yes down I go I go mr. Mertz I go I
don't believe the first two people and
she goes yeah oh my god okay and then
everyone goes back to work humans say
there is man she's like yeah I'm like I
was like um were they were they white
and she's like yeah yeah they like yeah
they were white
Am I Oh a few men say to raise my hand
she's like yes al I mean she's like him
do you work I'm like he sweat doing I'll
god she's like yes I'm my camera if Adam
and Eve were white and they were the
first two people then how do we have any
other rings I we have Sean over here I
know I said that I got a really other
races how do we have black people and
then and then everybody just slowly
looked up from their book and was like
no I was gonna pull out got a point you
got a point
and she goes well guys and she stuck
together you can see a little bit of
like little stuttering a little bit
because she does know how to navigate in
juice well guys you know it is like the
Bible she was made up of like like
parables
those are like stories to help you be a
better person but maybe you know you
guys should know now then you know maybe
not everything in the Bible is real all
night but Wow freaked the [ __ ] out
everyone's eyes scream what what do you
mean what it was not real what are you
talking about people are raising their
hand like asking like certain stories
like what about Cain Anejo about that
Bush did anybody thought she's like no I
don't know if that really happened and
people what the [ __ ]
and then this girl's in this a Catholic
school category at all so he's really
blowing my yeah everyone's like what do
I want like what about what about this
story what about Cain evil what about
progress and she's like I'm not really
sure if that's how it happens and Tania
black her on the class gets up and she
goes she goes what about Noah in the ark
and she's like I don't I don't think
that that's how we go just like she goes
I don't think that's how it happened
sometimes it literally gets upset and I
range you well then how do we have
hierarchy I literally got no idea what
out I go what also I meant it innocently
but I go also how do we have time I
should turn like flush red and
everything and we mean when I blew the
doors off the Bible that time I mean how
do I mean how did she get out here I was
about to say has so many kids had to go
and fell away but it but it what was she
telling the truth yeah you know it's
just like that was one of you weren't
ready for that dose
my god she promised cookbooks I'm gonna
feel real she was teaching third grade
two years before now this would be no
problem yeah I not everything's real go
about your work
little did she know that's great without
we were more savvy than that like she
used to she was I remember everyone had
a crush on her and when she taught us we
were in fifth grade she was 23 yeah
could she tell you and she wished a
couple times exactly that's when your
heart rate we're in fifth right and she
she had Cameron come in one day with a
hickey and she tried to cover it up she
had a little scarf on but you could see
it and we kind of knew what it was and
the ball buses in the class I'd even in
fifth grade like hello my friend Mike
where he's in like double he's like I
miss Demarest you have a you have a rash
on your neck like just we knew it right
snickering and she's like oh she turned
who's pale she was a redhead usually
pale and she turned he'd [ __ ] run to
Joe thank you okay okay so I could do
that so I picked up picked up it's so
funny because like you just feel like
all those Barros outside of New York
City come like are like these stories
you know what I mean you just picture
these kids growing up especially like
with the guys on the show and stuff like
that and this story about getting the
fake IDs
I mean was everyone getting fake IDs
back because I never had a fake ID until
I was in college
oh yeah and I only use it like twice
yeah you didn't need it but like we had
heard that you can get fake IDs
everybody everybody everybody was doing
what was your plan
ours was McCrory's downtown if you went
there but it was it was a walking permit
oh no I mean you had it you had a
specific physical brick-and-mortar
location which we had that and then we
also had if you kind of resembled this
one that was floating around you could
take it oh yeah everybody needed help
yeah but we had a place you would go but
they wouldn't give you a driver's
license ID they'd give you just a like
just an ID for people like my
grandmother didn't drive she'd have a
dress yet I was like it looks like it's
just a ID to walk but they would do it
for you and put the wrong address and
every everything I thought was a picture
I'll [ __ ] it was officially illegal yeah
all we heard was like oh go to Times
Square area and they're on the corner
like the guys are like fake IDs fake IDs
and just find them yeah so like I to one
day like this is a day so it was like
five of us six off and we
take the ferry we take the train we saw
no just walking around tongs grilling
and like how familiar with New York with
you guys at that age yes and no yeah you
know I may be like 17 still intimidating
I didn't like hang out there and bars I
didn't like work there yet so it was
like I would go there once in a while a
specific place yes but I didn't roam
much yes you know so the and also the
four of us kind of up to no good
you kind of had I kind of felt it a
little bit the world was rolling around
Times Square which wasn't like it's
cleaned up now it was a little bit
different like yeah Eric I was 20
holy [ __ ] that was 23 years ago so yeah
and so there's shady people and waiting
when I got was just way too and sure
enough you hear guys the viewing figured
a fake ID so like we caught one like
this is it guys isn't it so like I think
ID you know yes Wow one please yes my
friends and I will have one fake ID each
please and then he's a cowboy
and this guy's fast talker right he said
yeah I think I did a great great gods
come on come on come on me guys we'll go
up to the shop Lagaan so we start
following this guy and it's like five
six of us you know what follows guys
he's talking fast I guess what we're
gonna do real easy I'm gonna take you to
the shop then wait downstairs we'll
bring one by one you get that's we photo
take it takes a few minutes to process
we'll take your money away you know he
tells us like whatever it is like 30
bucks whatever each well I got yeah yeah
cool he's a gay he's like and he's
making he makes it calls now he wasn't
making calls oh he had a deeper I know
he kept telling me I gotta just get in
touch with the guys they I just gotta
get in touch today so we walked to one
place we walk in it's a Chinese
restaurant
oh my god he's like just sit here for a
second there's a guy you know why we
gotta go to the other place go to the
other place and nothing like he's
talking so fast and we're so excited to
get the fake IDs then nothing's ringing
to us like something's wrong yeah follow
me again you know what is I gotta go at
it so anyway we end up going in another
you just going from Chinese food place
Anjali so he sits us down and he goes
alright he sits us across from him and
he was right everybody money up front so
like right and he goes all right because
I gotta just check to make sure it's not
counterfeit none of this is counterfeit
cash he pulls out a pencil so he's here
I everybody put your money up so he put
up on money I'm like 30 bucks and he
takes a pencil eraser he starts the race
the bill like being like he's a guy this
one's good this one's good it's what a
pencil is all right it's all right he
goes here's what we're going to do the
guys up stood there the photos
photography studios upstage goby gonna
get you shot make sure you like it then
we going to profit I'll put him back
down to you and we'll bring one guy
everyone guys I got we hit great this is
great walleye we're gonna get I beats me
good idea and he's like yeah so then he
goes I here's what I gotta do I'm gonna
go upstairs to talk to him he's going to
come back down so he collects all the
[ __ ] money and he's and what heats
I'm just like yeah see him to death
because he's intimidating we don't know
he's like alright I'm gonna go upstairs
I'm gonna be right back that good and
I'm like yeah good good you know and he
goes to walk out and as soon as he gets
the door he swings the door open
plainclothes cops rush in shove him back
in they have they have their guns out
they have the badges and I know that
they didn't have their badges out
because as a day goes down they go
police everybody freeze in the Chinese
food restaurant like this like thirty
regular patrons everybody said please
throw them up against the wall he's a
guy to do nothing he's in a leather
jacket I saw patting him down like
everybody don't move and they're just
it's a [ __ ] sting right so we have
five Ducks are swinging in the wind
addition there's three of my friends are
over there me my buddy Mike are right by
the door the cops came in they went
forward past us so there's no one in
between us Mendoza we look at each other
work should be [ __ ] leave so well
okay so we just get up and casually walk
out where they told everyone to freeze
yeah so we casually walk out we look
each other we run across the street down
the block it into like a vestibule of
like a CVS and what I call my god I
can't believe this is happening since
we're like are we going to jail like the
other side yeah
did he and also we all go to jail like
what did we do what are the implications
here are parents gonna [ __ ] kill us
our friends okay like what's going on
like how big yeah I don't care our
friends okay was on your mind well we'll
wait looking no we would know we really
work I grew we were like what the [ __ ]
going on because and so we're sitting
and we're watching the door of the
Chinese food place from across the
street in a vestibule and no one's
coming out and it's it's 5-10 minutes
and no one's coming out I'm like what is
going on the 80s movie version is your
friends run up to and then you see him
get shot in the back
we're thinking the worst and then all of
a sudden it comes over me and I go wait
a minute
now I'm savvy the whole time he's trying
to erase my [ __ ] Andrew Jackson I
don't think anything of it now I go wait
a minute watch this is this was a
full-on scam those weren't cops they
wanted to scare us so we ran out and
they kept on money those guys are in on
it with him they yeah come in they yell
freeze we get scared we run out right
and now they're all just probably in
there they're gonna leave they went out
the back door it was never a stink
did you I could I said did you see they
didn't show badges oh they had guns
he said they'd pull guns right now I
thought they did yeah I [ __ ] thought
they did ever gone out but was really
the owner maybe maybe I saw rich I saw
no no I saw the gun
yeah they had gun here but not bad job
to eat because I know we saw guns were
like what the [ __ ] was that
so uh so we go so now we start getting
like mad I was like we gotta go back
over there we don't know what's going on
like oh they didn't come out either so
what if they took our friends in the
back weren't there beating them up like
we didn't know anything so we wait to be
like let's just go back and we go cross
the street we walk slow we get back to
the Chinese place we go we walk in or AJ
can play it's business as usual man what
a friend Amendola friends are not there
the cops are not there the guy is not
there no remnants of chaos people are
eating their chicken we're like our
minds are blown what now we're like what
the [ __ ] where are our friends so we're
like what are we gonna do and I don't
know it was before cellphones so we walk
out of the Chinese restaurant we're just
walking down the street we don't know
where to go who to talk to and we're
walking in about a couple of minutes
later a taxicab pulls over rolls down
the window you guys get in the car
so we're like what he goes I'm a cop get
in the car we have your friends so we
look at each other we are we get it we
get in the car they take us to the
precinct
undercover cop and he goes yeah you were
in the middle of a [ __ ] sting
operation and we're like how did you
know to pinpoint that moment he goes you
[ __ ] five seven year-old white kids
following this guy three times we're
through different red light little
subject we picked it up immediately you
know so we get to the police station and
you know he's like listen and he's like
you got to tell me what exactly what
happened because
all these little like intricacies like
if he took the money out of our hair out
asking that's an extra charge you know
like the difference between grand
larceny and robbery non so we're just
nervous to rat on the guy he's like they
like look it's you don't if you don't
rattle if you don't know right on if you
don't tell us everything what I forgot
to put him away
did he leave did he order you tea he did
order us came to the cop like did he
order you how do you think that's an
extra five years hahahahaha he say
please and banging no and well so yeah
so we're just like yeah and we he he we
said everything and they're like are
we're going to take your money they like
we got to put into evidence and we'll
call you in like 30 to 60 should
probably come again and after it's all
done we never went back yeah went home
had to tell our parents and my buddy
Mike was like my best friend his dad
flipped out and told him he forbid him
to hang out with me anymore
really I we worked together at a deli
and so Mike came and I like he's like
pissed at me like I was like the
ringleader and him coming in everyone
went buddy likes I talked to my dad
she doesn't know where you get off
selector and on me he's like he says we
can't talk anymore so it's gonna be a
while and I'm like all right and I'm
like we have to work together at the
deli I'm like not talk each other for a
while he's like I run to this data but I
mean like I wrote down earlier wrong
place wrong time if you had not a
biography that's what I feel like it
would be and you're always in the wrong
place like this one well these sound
like to assure these is baseball card oh
that's another gonna test my fancy my
dad's came to [ __ ] in his week both
collected rye bar my truck one time
because he was moving and I got it back
and like over the course of next two
weeks
everywhere I looked at final of
Baltimore Orioles car cuz this kids an
Orioles fan
Sheila's come on I took old Oriole a
stack of them and I hid him under his
floor mat like everything all through
there I guarantee there's no help on
that well you have like a card show I
did now I mean I collected them in the
neighborhood as a kid and we would trade
and yeah you know and then I still have
the locker remember it looked like a
little lock or you open up and had two
slots for each team and I still have my
yeah all my car was out no legislated
out I would like a like I would like
hand categorize my collection and I
would buy the books to see what they're
worth that was one back
yeah Beckett that was so cool Kazan next
month it would go up 20 cents I had like
I was like [ __ ] Bugsy I had like an
accountant I would be like alright this
Mattingly card went from 240 to 260 I'm
up twenty cents like I was doing my net
worth in baseball cause they used to
have these card shows where like a bunch
of different card dealers would they
just would be like uh you know like I'm
all over there yeah yeah we had tables
here and I go my buddy Jay and he gets
you me pay admission took two bucks and
you get to go and everybody selling all
different things and he gets into his
head that was going to take cards like
he was very lacks like you know people
walk away from their table and walk back
and stuff so like they just leaving all
the cards now and I was when I was in
grammar schools young I was like
probably like maybe fifth sixth grade
and I was wearing a fanny pack at the
time was very involved
yes I'm sure and they just say hey man
it was hot it was a hot ticket so I was
wearing a fanny pack and my buddy he
like without even like referring to me
he went he took a card and he's like
here and he put him keeping you all the
time fanny pack it's important to know
like everybody's giving you I remember I
remember three of the cards Darryl
Strawberry tops great rookie card yeah
rob kirby puckett
Oh tops then there was also a Clemens
the update set guard what's that that's
like his original rookie the update you
November they use come out with 85 top
80 fat well they had the helicopter and
the update become like guys that came up
and last lemons update 85 update I think
is his real rookie okay his real rookie
card I think it is real know my or I
might have gotten eight no wasn't the 86
comes I remember the 86 coming that's
how much I have I could pick a gay -
yeah the would the bla that was 87 was
sometimes the color be off and the guys
look a little blue at the Kirby Pucket
of this curry buckets why couldn't -
strawberry Mattingly and whose five
cards and then I think it's the Clemens
and he put him extorted wall of mind we
were taking him from different he had
taken from different tables and he's
putting in my favorite bang and you know
they're in there I'm zipped back up
walking around nobody saying [ __ ] so
well I got her
you know whatever so my dad was dropped
us off who was picking us up so well I
got might it was time for my dad to come
get us so we start to walk on the front
edge all right when we get to the front
entrance guys step right in front of us
I'm gonna give me two wait right there
and we're like what's the matter just
just wait right there and at that moment
my dad was walking in and he saw the two
guys tell us you have to wait right here
it was puts the batter and he goes we
caught these guys steal baseball coins
and my dad turns to me oh man yes like
it was like Bubba ray Dudley but he got
like a vein he thinks is true and I go I
didn't say no and yeah he my dad who's
never cursed in front of me never laid a
hand on me in my life he picks me up by
my shirt up he was so mad he picks me up
by my shirt off the ground I mean I was
you know yeah eighty pound I was a twig
and he's like it's just how I raised you
and I got so scared I pissed my father
literally let go completely right there
in the face but I nearly pissed my pants
in the car that I don't know if he saw
like in that moment I was all like and I
testified I was just like oh my god he
put me back down and he get we get in
the car we go home and we I lived in
these we lived in these garden apartment
so my friend lived right in the building
next to me so all the kids they were all
congregated we all hung outside together
on the same block so my dad brought me
upstairs he screamed you know that cry
you get when your cable you can't
breathe yeah yeah he's screaming at me
and there was a there was a sect we had
a sectional couch and when a caddy
cornered on the corner like rounded
there was a space like a good hon go
seek spot I was a real squared in the
couch yeah yeah and he's screaming at me
and everything and I'm like I'm like
he's just not letting up and I'm so like
and so I'm crying I go behind there and
I get it and I go in under the thing and
I'm just crying behind the couch he said
I'm going out I'll be back later and
he's like I don't want to you know
you're not going out your punch Allah he
leads I'm so [ __ ] traumatized by this
I'm stunned they're crying I don't stop
I'm just there hours passed
it's nightfall he come nightfall I
thought high school none of them I
didn't get up and I didn't bother to
turn on the lights in house and it
so when he comes home he open the door
pitch black in half he turns on the
light like he's like hello Sal and he
goes and I'm in the spot he left me and
he just was like so sorry he like fell
so many hours later all right
Terrebonne homicide he was like I look
he's like I overreacted I'm sorry I just
don't want you to steal a lot but the
hole you need in any merry man you're
gonna take anything at all I mean
Quisenberry
nothing Liz but uh the whole time right
my friend who and there's a summer
select the windows the upon were open he
went home told his fans his dad laughed
it off he was out the entire time the
entire time I was like literally
hyperventilating behind the couch the
windows were open I heard him outside
for hours playing they thought nothing
of it his parents but my dad art is
bikes bugs and ripped them all up but
everything just came back don't buy my
dad near stop okay we're in she is in
Roebuck you might know it yeah Taylor
good to see us so we're we're in Sears
and it's packed and my dad knows I can
get a wrestling figure and you remember
those those rubber ones that like that
huh yeah yeah so Jesse the body right so
my dad says I get a feudal governor yeah
and were walking around see is my dad
getting whatever needs and it's it's
time to leave he doesn't find what he
needs but I'm holding the rest on this
whole time so we go to wait on the line
lines pretty big the line was a [ __ ]
show and see us like 20 people on line
it's born an old lady behind a beginning
so wait another line my dad's getting a
patient might have to get a patient
everything is like can we get it next
time I'm like not audio episode my world
I'm like no you don't really get it we
don't know get me we gonna I see him I
remember looking at him he's gettin
frustrating is it you know I gotta get
something else let's walk around so we
go to walk around and he's like I sold
the Jesse the body and I and like he
pops it out of the [ __ ] plastic my
dad he had a lot of late in life he
doesn't want to wait in line he has to
go right so he pumps out and he's like
no we're just talking he's not so I did
make you believe like I'm out seeing
what he's doing and he goes out because
you know what let's uh we'll go we'll go
out to work this way and we will happen
we can't walk out attack he's not really
sorry trust me I'll come back I'll pay
for the promise I'll come back I'll pay
for it oh my god we get we walk out the
door walking to the car and I stop
and is what are you doing I'm like I
can't do it he's like while I'm like I
can't steal that I was a glassful steal
like you all the way from steal now you
go we can't steal this thing and I just
sort of laid back on and he's like
you're right
like goes back in gets the cardboard in
the plastic
please i but that we go online like 20
minutes I made him pay for so you know
if he didn't yell me about the baseball
cards you would have got off hell yeah
sure was little taste of the romance
again like I gave it to him I'm a bird
apart I've only stolen a whole few
things since then after four people have
death from a lot of my friends like I
this all comes out like I don't I don't
steal but I'd have friends who like that
growing up like they stole that was a
thing like they got something out of it
they like like like stealing yeah I
don't know and I never I never had that
well clearly you did I started be
clearly clearly it did I thought of the
whole story I just told you I sold to it
I was working on it yeah awesome man I
don't know where we're at guys number
two now we're there man there's been a
lot of [ __ ] fun thank you so much for
coming on a great hydration right you're
great what's on will you one more time
plug your social media your show
whatever you'd like please yeah at Sal
Vulcano on Instagram and Twitter
we're on tour you can go the Tenderloin
calm we talked all year long
and I guess we'll be at the Greek on
September 24th in LA and then you got
the cruise hang on that cruise and
watching the show definitely watch the
ship dirty sometimes there's b210 truTV
awesome in style thanks for coming on
man thank you so much for having me as
always Jay Larson comic I'm Jay Larson
comedy across all social media Ryan
sitcom Ryan Sickler all social media
we'll talk to you all next Tuesday